[Music]
let's talk about badb or Benito the
businessman Beyond music, who
is that person? Benito businessman has been
created over time and not While I'm
growing While
I'm finding other ways to
express myself and to create myself at the end of the
day  Music comes from that whole part
because it is what I do that I am
passionate about and thank God it has
left me fruits that I can continue
to invest in other areas but Benito is not
much different from being a businessman
no no he is not much different from what  I say it about
He who makes music because he
goes hand in hand with the other because I
repeat it is through music and everything I
have achieved that gives me the
opportunity to create these other things
who are your
inspirations I am a big fan of
music since I was little and And as
I always say at home it was heard from my
country, a lot of salsa was heard from
mommy, it was a lot of ballads, a lot of merengue
from the Dominican Republic of Puerto
Rico, also if we let ourselves be carried away by
the reggaeton genre Well, always  I have
said that what Teo Calderón was was. I
think that one of those first
artists that I became obsessed with and I wanted and
I wanted to do it almost to this bikos who was
the first rap and urban artist that
I heard for the first time and then here he
comes  Dari yank Don omel
este Calle 13 René
Ed and buo and many more exponents of the
reggaetón genre that I always
listened to and and and I always say that they are
part of that
[Music]
inspirations I know that also V part of
this competition that we are doing in
October you go  to donate 00,000 to no small
business, this Latino. What is the
importance of doing
that? I think that because of what I just
said, sometimes those same people who
sometimes don't take the first step is because
maybe they don't have the resources.  or
they don't have the support so I
just want to be that
that that motivation and that that push
that can change maybe
someone's day or even their life and that is what it is that is what
I at least always
like.  What I like to do is see
another person succeed and see another
person achieve what they dream of and knowing
that I was able to be part of that process is
super stupid and not in a way like I
'm going to throw it in your face later No
thanks  Not for me, on the contrary, it's like I
feel like I was part of it with you and and
and that's all. I think that what
you're
doing with the Good Bunny Foundation always fills me in one way. We can't
talk a little about that, how
did you create that? Let's say.  You got that idea
of ​​creating a foundation. I think it
comes from that feeling of always
wanting to contribute something and help. I come back and
repeat, I come from a neighborhood
and I know what the needs are,
upbringing, too, look.  In my house
I saw how my father was always
contributing to the neighborhood without having much. You
understand me about how little we had and
sometimes as a child I didn't even
understand it. Sometimes there are many things that
I would have loved to have had as a child,
a lot of resources.  initiative program and I
have witnessed how sports and
music can change the life of
anyone, little kids from the neighborhood who
made it and are now in the Major
Leagues, see them How they have How they have
managed to succeed in life Well, that's
That  is the
main intention What has been the moment the
best moment of your career so far
the best moment of my
career hand I never have that answer
because every day is the best
moment of my real career every
year is the best moment of  my career
everything, every step I take is the best, it
's a bigger step and that's how it's been since.
That's how it's been since the beginning and I
remember when I released
chambea I'm worse and I said devil and what a
bigger song I'm going to release now
and  then that's like that doesn't
exist for me there is no limit there
is no ceiling and and and and we continue working and
doing things that take us to another
level and to another level and when
the levels no longer exist we create it
So the best moment of my  race I
will be able to tell you when
[Music]
ends